welcome back HC appointment no one's all
coming yeoman's second class Joshua
Kelly also known as drag queen Harvey
Daniels announced on Tick Tock he would
be a digital ambassador to the U.S Navy
Seals he was one of several diverse
faces chosen to reach a wide range of
potential candidates Navy said as it
seeks to recruit more gen Z service men
and service women and apparently service
them well I'm joined from New York I
form a U.S Navy SEAL Rob O'Neill the man
of course who killed Osama Bin Laden on
that incredible raid Rob I did think of
you the moment I heard about this story
as to what on Earth you would make of
this new recruitment Drive
by your old people I mean what what is
going on here
well thanks for having me Paris I don't
know what's going on here it's for some
reason they like to go woke a lot excuse
me a lot of different places and uh the
woke move is not working at all I'm all
about freedom and people want to do what
they want do it behind closed doors even
out to see if the guys want to have a
drag show my first question would be
where's the chief's mess and who made
this decision but if they want to do it
you know what goes on and see stays at
Sea however using for an enlisted sailor
enlisted Soldier should not be famous in
the first place you shouldn't really be
on social media certainly certainly not
be advertising for the Navy on a Chinese
Espionage site which is Tick Tock
um and what we're supposed to be doing
is is projecting Alliance solidarity's
forward defense and deterrence and to
have a drag queen uh that's not going to
deter the Chinese who are actually
trying to globally take over and to me
this is just part of a a long-standing
scheme that goes way back to the USSR
where uh they're trying to demoralize
our uh make the make make make something
not normal just so that we think it's
normal and then they can also Robert
does this follows the course of Fury
over the Bud Light campaign using Dylan
Mulvaney the the the trans influencer uh
who until very recently identified as
male again massive backlash against Bud
Light in fact I think sales down 25 or
something you can't help thinking this
will have the exact opposite effect that
the Navy hope it will why would people
watch this the right people for the Navy
Seals and think that's what I want to
join I don't get it they won't but Bud
Light didn't realize who Their audience
was and again not that there's anything
wrong with what's going on but you're
going to lose your audience and the the
people who aren't being heard about here
are the men and women who are now
serving in the military and the young
men and women who might potentially join
that maybe won't because of stuff like
this it's it's the there's a there's a
cutoff in leadership where they're
making a decision based on what a
politician wants them to make so they
can get a job later and the politician's
happy and uh the news media for the
majority won't cover it because it's not
the the woke leftist thing to do I mean
like I said I'm all about Freedom do
what you want but we need the the
military is not there for a lot of this
command climate how how are you feeling
today nonsense it's supposed to be be
are You Ready for War today because you
should be and when we need to go we go
and then all the other nonsense which
comes with after the war is down to the
diplomats they're using the military for
the wrong reasons this is the wrong way
to recruit and I I talk to people in the
military I travel the country I travel
the world and I it's not just scientific
polls that I listen to I'm getting the
pulse of the people on the majority of
people don't want this for that reason
not that there's not a place for it this
certainly isn't it you know we began
this show you may not have seen this but
we got Michelle because the the labor
party leader here who's tipped to be the
next prime minister the way the polls
are going has has announced that he
doesn't think the public care about woke
issues this is the kind of thing that
I'm talking about when I say they
absolutely do because I can't imagine
many people watching this to I'm not
going to watch this story and think this
is wokery gone completely bonkers
yeah it certainly is the there's like I
said there's a time and place for
everything but even with like liberal
issues they're being hijacked by
leftists because they're going so far to
the left that it doesn't even make sense
anymore it's it's uh it becomes so
partisan that they're they're making
decisions that that don't need to be
made they're they're one of the things
they're doing is they're talking
themselves into losing as opposed to
just sometimes the simplest answer is
right in front of your face there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
making a simple answer and the simple
answer the way to recruit young men
especially in this country is with the
United States Marine and a flaming sword
fighting the dragon that's the people
you want in the military I mean not that
we don't want everyone and again I don't
want to be I don't want to be you know
exclude anybody but when we took 23 of
the most highly qualified men on the
mission to kill Bin Laden not one of us
cared what the other sexual identity was
we cared if they're are there guns
loaded are their batteries fresh and if
I get shot can you carry me back to my
family that's that's all we care about
we're keeping it simple not not what do
you do on the weekend to entertain
yourself behind closed doors it doesn't
matter it's not important stop making it
an issue yeah it's just are you good
enough right are you good enough to do
your job and potentially save the people
you're with from getting killed I mean
that seems to me to be the criteria to
be a Navy SEAL hey I know that's the
reason I got picked it wasn't because I
was the smartest guy in the room I just
happened you could point me in the right
direction tell me who the bad guy is and
hopefully I shoot the right person I was
smart enough to do that we can leave the
other stuff to other people but uh do
your job do it right and then come home
you know let's give you the other night
I was watching 0.30 of course about the
bin Laden raid and then a week uh did I
watch Captain Phillips and I also
watched with my son's Lone Survivor and
I suddenly remembered that you were on
all three of those missions I watched
those movies you know and enjoy them as
entertainment what the hell is it like
for you to watch these movies when you
were actually on all of them Lone
Survivor was actually on today just an
hour ago when I was watching part of it
a great movie great acting the only
complaint is they couldn't find
mountains that were actually steep
enough for the actor to jump off of what
these these Heroes actually did and uh
you can't explain the heat that's there
and what it's like to have an enemy
trying to kill you and then Captain
Phillips you know leaving your
daughter's classroom on your birthday
jumping into the Indian Ocean 16 hours
later than rescuing Richard Phillips on
each on Easter Sunday and then uh you
know Zero Dark Thirty that's just proof
that there's one big team the woman that
found Bin Laden was a woman an actual
tough woman that found Bin Laden if you
want to recruit use her if you want to
get a real a really an awesome female
operator watch that movie try to be like
Maya the characters great movies all um
they they didn't have there wasn't
enough time to tell all the stories but
yeah it is funny though I'm just proof
that uh wherever you are be there and uh
anything can happen in your life did you
ever meet that that lady Maya for the
zero the real one
yeah I met her I'm um I met her the
first day she was one that said the
reason you're here is because this is as
close as we've ever been to Osama Bin
Laden we did the mission I saw her a few
months later in a bar in New York over a
beer and I said hey how was all the
blowback and she said I didn't even get
a parking spot
you guys real heroes Rob it's great to
talk to you uh thank you so much I the
old phrase go woke go broke at some
point they're going to realize it's
actually true
at some point they're going to prove
themselves right yeah exactly Rob great
to see you all the best thank you
anytime